every day millions of data points are
being generated about your health what
if all this data could be combined and
shared with healthcare teams to improve
patient care the reality is that
healthcare is very different from retail
or banking or travel
and digital transformation in healthcare
needs people who are bilingual
fluent in the powerful new digital tools
that are emerging
but also in the culture and workflows of
real-life medicine
we have to take a healthcare-centered
view of tech disruption in digital
health you'll explore the opportunities
and caveats related to the widespread
adoption of digital tools and healthcare
you'll acquire new frameworks to help
you navigate stakeholder needs
create value
foster trust and engagement
demonstrate improved outcomes
and develop sustainable business models
and all of this
in the unique context of the healthcare
ecosystem i really think we're the first
inning of what's possible in digital
health and
we'll go on a journey over the next
decade we're more and more and more of
clinical services will be pushed either
into the pocket into the home or in the
cloud but ultimately people are
expecting for that data to be used for
the purposes of improving their health
care outcomes the most important thing
that we can do is how we can create a
path forward to leverage data to really
help people get insights that can help
them better engage in their health and
better understand what's going on right
now this program is for anyone who wants
to learn more about leading digital
enabled initiatives in healthcare the
future of healthcare is digital